les sénateurs de gauche n'ont pas vu
leurs amendements retenus dans le vote
final du gouvernement musulmane ils ont
quand même deux minutes pour défendre
leurs amendements deux minutes qu'ils
prennent et pour marquer le coup face à
cette situation exceptionnelle pour
donner du rythme nous ont-ils dit ils
ont décidé de déployer tout sous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi les
mêmes éléments de langage à chacune de
leurs prises de parole je vous propose
d'en écouter un extrait vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous sommes pas dupe et les Français
n'ont plus ne lâcheront rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez
que nous laissions le sujet des
retraites et les retraites des Français
entre les seuls mains vont seulement des
droits de coalisées mais nous ne sommes
pas dupe et les Français non plus nous
ne lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons
pas alors ça fait des heures que ça dure
vous l'imaginez ça commence à agacer un
petit peu à droite je voulais revenir
sur les mots de fin de ces éléments de
langage nous ne lâcherons rien
évidemment ils ont en tête la
mobilisation la manifestation qui va
s'élancer et dans quelques minutes c'est
une manière de maintenir la pression et
de galvaniser les manifestants et
[Musique]